[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis u.s.
chess champs calm presents the third
annual winter chest classic
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the 2019
winter chess classic my name is Caleb
Denby I'm joined as always by the
wonderful Sabina foyer and we will be
giving the coverage for the games today
in round two it was an interesting round
one for sure some very interesting games
and even when we left off actually
yesterday there were some interesting
turn around yeah absolutely
why don't we take a look and see where
we stand after that first round of play
in the a group our standings are Jeffrey
Zhang he's no stranger to his classic
series he's the number one seed in this
event of course some of his past results
here in st. Louis include winning the
2018 and 2019 spring chess classics so
hoping to add a third classic title
maybe someday he'll hold one for every
season but chasing him is also have on
his caboose Ian on one point out of one
and then a myriad of players all drew
their first games with sethu and Varro
Kobe and rounding out the field in the a
group and over in the B group why don't
we check out what's going on there with
the standings Melek Cotchin has one
point out of one as as does Justin Wang
the youngster Justin of course taking
down his fellow kiddo Christopher you of
course they are the number one and
number two you 14 players in the
Americas by feat a ranking once again
another myriad of players all on 1/2
point after that first round hoping to
turn positive today and round 2 and
Sergei Arenberg and Christopher you
hoping to get on the board in this round
of play why don't we check out what kind
of format these players are playing in
with our time control and things like
that there are of course 210 player
around Robbins that is the a group and
the B group that we
just took a look at the time control for
the event is 90 minutes for the first 40
moves plus a 30 minute plus 30 minutes
added on for the remainder of the game
after move 40 there is also a 30-second
increment added on from move one there's
also a draw rule in effect there are no
draw offers before blacks thirtieth move
however the game could still be drawn of
course by by repetition which is great
because well it means we'll see a lot of
fighting chests and really yeah that's
the idea behind the rule that make these
players play for it and hopefully we we
see some decisive results because of
this rule why don't we take a look at
the schedule if the players are playing
in it's not too complicated this time
around 1:00 p.m. every day
with no rest days in between until that
final round 9 well of course the round
starts two hours earlier to make room
for a playoff if necessary of course our
show doesn't start at 1:00 p.m. it
starts at 3:30 p.m. every day
besides for that last day when we will
also be be moving a bit earlier of
course we'd like to thank you guys for
joining us on social media keeping up
with us in the YouTube chat we are
taking a look at it there I want to say
a quick hello to everybody
hello to Cece hello to siege sieges sug
amen go Lucas Sandra Pippo and everyone
else still still watching you can get
involved on Twitter as well using the
hashtag winter chess classic and if
you'd like to follow the games for
yourself you can always do so on us
chess champs comm see what's going on
click on the games you want to click on
and get that engine analysis as well in
case you're not satisfied with with me
and Sabina well with that of Mines
why don't you miss let's get started and
I believe already have some results so
maybe we can just tell everyone the
rounds first pairings and I'll get
started with ya of the games so of
course the pairings in group a have Seth
you playing against Rena and juma by of
Victor Erdos playing against Alexa
Serena vara Cobian against Daniel nerd
it's key and then your tournament
co-leader Jeffrey Zhong has actually
already drawn his game
against Sam 7 so Jeffery moves to one
and a half out of two but that leaves
the the door open for our key matchup of
the day where Gregorio oberon is taking
on Havana's caboose Ian and if GU Busey
would win today he would move into clear
first place but Sabina what's going on
in the game is that looking lately it
seems to be a very tough game this is
the position the current position right
now I think white is really close to the
problem winning here so unfortunately we
might not see caboose Ian getting I mean
maintaining the lead yeah fortunate for
him we're not trying to show that we're
taking any sides or anything like that
and just it's nice to he has had a
really great game yesterday and he came
down here analyzing it and taking us
over through it and today he has this
position and I believe it's going to be
very tough very very active bishops for
white as well as to passed pawns coming
down the board yeah it's going to be
tough to stop all these threats for a
bonus yes and his bishops are not doing
very much unfortunately this rook also
in a6 is kind of out of play
so it's going to be difficult I suggest
to maybe go back from the beginning and
just take a look at how yeah absolutely
f3 would have arrived in this position
so seems like a boos Ian decided to kind
of do the same as yesterday he played
with with the white pieces he played
reverse Kings Indian right so today he's
going with the black pieces trying to do
the same but of course it's not you know
it's not going to work the same way
plus you're white so what goes for the
fianchetto yeah it's a line and this is
usually pretty positional I think and
plans are this this 94 I it's not one of
the main lines here for black I think
black usually tries to prepare to play
e5 so we can things like Knight bt7 yeah
9b d7
sometimes 96 you often see ideas also
with if you don't want to to develop the
night just yet you can also play c6 and
try to play with ideas with Queen a 5-4
B 5 there are a lot of ideas that the
black and try to to have in these
positions but 94s maybe an idea to try
to take advantage of the fact that white
has not developed yet the 19 see three
right so because the knight is not there
you can try to take control over this
outpost yeah absolutely and now if the
way if white were to develop to c3 black
might capture of course I I think it is
and try to mess up a little bit white
pawns maybe an idea like c5 also would
be nice here I think for black to try to
it opens up to the dark squared Bishop
moving this night and I guess it doesn't
make White's development a little bit
awkward a little bit yeah that's why
white has to prepare if they're going to
develop this knight or they can develop
it in d2 which a parent has done in the
next movie he first played Queen to c2
attacking the knight so now you're
asking black a question okay are you
going to keep your knight they're really
go back of course at this level nobody
is going to retreat there's no point to
come forward and then go back right so
f5 seems pretty natural to maintain the
night over 84 and now we seen Knight B
to d2 chasing the night once again away
and unfortunately black is not ready
with the 1987 937 to come to f6 and make
sure the night is going to be well
protected and staying there it's always
annoying to have such a knight I always
I remember as a kid I really disliked
when my opponents played the night they
are kids right
what am I going to do yeah you never
really want to play f3
especially with a bishop on on g2 like
this of course because you would close
your bishop right this bishop would be
close and also you know this diagonal
would get open and you're told no don't
do that you would sometimes do it in
so well that's not here yes but the way
I've always understood it is you know
why it hasn't really done anything wrong
right
white developed a piece on every turn
and then black is kind of the one who
deviated from promoting principles by
playing this night from f6 all the way
up to e4 before short so wait usually
should have you know something of course
white hasn't done anything wrong so
black doesn't really deserve to have a
strong night button that is true that is
true so that's why here black is kind of
forced to give up the night I mean just
traded Bishop takes per natural and now
black is trying to get some space on the
kingside and oftentimes we would want to
see this d5 push and get more space but
the the idea is when you feeling
healthier Bishop in g2 you really want
to make sure that that Bishop remains
opened so you try to avoid ideas with d5
or n times if you can so that's what a
partner's doing just taking any five
pawn takes and Bishop b4 now to create
their natural and where we have
completed our development with white so
it's time to bring the rooks on the open
files from d1 Queen f6 and now Bishop c3
yeah White's pieces all all look very
harmonious to me yes the bishop in the
night work fall against that e5 pawn the
Queen on c2 doesn't seem to be doing
much but you can imagine maybe like b3
and Queen B 2 would be very nice idea
and you know blacks pieces seem a little
bit undeveloped I'm not so sure if I
agree with the way that black has played
this opening actually yeah probably 1997
a little bit earlier whether I would
have played 97 before going 94 but right
could be some kind of preparation that
black has had yeah in this position
black does have quite a bit of central
space I guess this is the the
compensation for his pieces being a
little bit undeveloped but how did they
a game actually progressed yeah no now
he has to be careful because of course
you know he needs to finish his
development so right
he played Queen to e7 in order to be
able probably to push this pawn to to e4
and of course he would have wanted to
play that but the bishop wasn't before
they're also Knight takes e5 threats in
the air yeah it's possible 90 85 route
65 and there may be f4
yeah I'm not sure if it's actually
totally working now that I look at it
but your queen is having a good map just
prepared yeah just preparing the the
development and now e4 I really like
this move because you are trying to make
sure that black doesn't push before the
only problem is you allow for f4 which
is what happened in the game but of
course now black is not so ready
yesterday caboose I was telling us how
his rook you know anyone was anyone it
was already for some things with brakes
with with a 4 but here the rookies in
the 8th again it's not really NFA to
support this f4 push and sometimes you
want to play Bishop g4 and Patricia and
the knight but now we need to waste one
more time so upon retreat captured ok
and now we see e5 once again so now hmm
and I started liking this position for
right yeah there's this idea that you
mentioned you want to keep the bishop on
g2 open yes so even though white plays
d4 which locks the bishop out temporary
he had this this very concrete idea
that's five and so that the bishop
doesn't stay out of out of the game for
long
so maybe black would not play a 40 meter
maybe he can just hold on a little bit
to this position although it's no it's
okay I really wish I could play maybe 96
if I'm 95 something like that yeah I
think you can just play very simply with
white maybe Rick fe1 yeah for sure
there's more pressure and of he takes
that five yes yes just putting more
pressure first in any five and then you
know then we want to open up we're not
going to rush with the trait but black
kind of helped white just get the
position that they wanted e 596 look
after you one strengthening this pawn 85
there should be six and now h4 very
interesting move by a pardon
yes is trying to go for this to try to
open up the diagonal maybe also some 95
and attracting some weaknesses he's
claiming a square for sure it does look
a little bit unnatural but it looks like
a very aggressive idea I'm not I don't
think I have any problem with it yeah I
I like it a your perfectly placed all
the pieces are perfectly play so you
need to try to find some ways to
activate the pieces even more so this
seems like a nice idea and I believe
this pawn in in in c4 should not be able
to be captured because a rookie yet
maybe Queenie for as well
rookie for a queen for one of those
seems to be working then we captured the
f4 pawn and why should be doing great I
mean this past pawn is going to be
awesome if you can eventually defend it
with another pawn so surah kahf 895 okay
so the bishop has to move what about
here Bishop takes c4 do we have
something similar hmm
it's an interesting question I don't see
it immediately
maybe there is b3 and then there's no
good square for this Bishop yeah and
then then we would would probably like
if you go back to a7 for example we
would take it and maybe Bishop t-55
steps so I guess you have to play like
Bishop or maybe we could see some play
me six this move could be kind of an
adverb all right very nasty but I don't
think you can come back to have seven
then so yes your basics would be forest
and that would be a little bit
unfortunate yeah you know almost
anything here right just Bishop b2 even
and there's pressure on the knight out
of play mm-hmm and we have of course
checks over here possible sacrifices at
some point h5 trying to weaken the King
even more all right so let's continue
with the game
engage change f3 and slowly pushing
black away Queen b3 very typical move in
pretty much any kind of openings I think
for right D for openings especially and
finally Black has committed to creating
some weaknesses for themselves h6 so now
g6 becomes the weakness and that's
probably exactly what the partner wanted
in this position yeah I mean H success
and benefits though as well right this
night has to move in and h4 seems to be
falling but it has to move but did it
okay he did not move the knight from I
mean a queen bee three certainly was
looking at that b7 pawn and since black
did not protect it apart and went for
Queen takes b7 it's too high class for
me my opponents X my pieces and you'll
know the way I use them that's true I
mean Queen d7 but we're talking but I
mean you go back here right then this
pawn is hanging this age for pawn is
hanging a 5 maybe yeah this of course
had to be no Prince idea yes because you
really don't want to allow this Queen to
be active right all avoid species are
more active so you really try to avoid
letting that Queen just come take
advantage of your own weak King because
after all White's King is pretty weak -
and now no pieces are protecting it so
Queen takes b7 seems like
a really great idea rook b8 Queen Texas
six rugby six and in this position you
ask me this book I did I was trying to
make like a big scene here you know but
this position why to move so part I
retreated the Queen to a four but there
is an amazing tactical idea here amazing
tactical idea and if you're watching
maybe you can just pause us for a second
and we're not doing an extra recording
but to try to find this move if you're
not if you haven't watched the game live
by now I'm never gonna find it
so tell me Queen f6 look at these Volvox
it's amazing and it seems to be working
because you are kind of taking advantage
of the fact that this King is in the
corner and the bishop gets to be opened
this rule gets to be open and can take
the Queen it's just if you do take the
Queen I do want to take Bishop takes
Queen all right Queen takes pawn all
right I haven't I haven't looked up that
far I I think I can probably just take
right I have an extra piece right
because I wanted earlier so basically
what I'm trying to do is go towards the
end game even if I don't have a
checkmate I'm trying to go towards the
end game and with a piece up I should
have no problem that the knight of seven
is going as well and I got rid of the
Queen which could attack this is the
this is so crazy you just hang your
queen here in f6 and pretty much all of
the four pieces can capture you but
neither of those is good and it doesn't
seem like Black has yeah nobody wants to
do but it's not so easy to make this
move I think although you do have ideas
when I have seven next because you are
scared that what is going to happen to
just moves out of the way yeah
see five checkers yeah and then you're
singing oh no and then they take my
queen someone's going to happen but I
think you're the specialty 474 should
work yeah and then if you take with
Czech rook takes I wanted to make that
intermediate movement now it doesn't
work and now once again I still have a
piece off with white and once you take
my queen of course and you should be
able to be winning pretty clearly for
white here so even if white doesn't keep
the peace what White's gonna win a
couple pawns for it yeah for example you
know like h6 g5 just just pawn takes g5
yes after Bishop takes f6 pawn f6
there's there's too many pawns
there's a lot of pawns and a piece and
King is weak yeah so I mean I was just
this this position should go in some
tactical books I think Caleb I mean yeah
and I just think it's so it's so cool
but okay you know it's not so easy to
play it the board I mean so Queen Queen
a4 and white is still having a great
position but now black gets to take
their piece back with HTA's g5 and now
of course you cannot capture back do not
dream of that because the Queen would
come yeah you want to be super careful
so you're gonna pattern one for Queen
III just trading the Queen's and
eventually we have seen he went for that
and game where he's better he has he had
this Bishop a5 after which he captures
the c7 pot and then you cannot take in a
three because we have this fork over
here of the two rooks yes the bishops
are just way too powerful here exactly I
think quite a bit of progress is
actually been made yeah so let's see
looks like we were over here so Bishop
f8 was playing uh-huh
Trey the bishops I think that makes
sense c5 was another move that white
could have tried to go for but maybe he
didn't want to give up this one the e3
pawn mm-hmm
just supposed to be porn so what
happened in game and let's see so Bishop
takes a fade route takes a fade East six
alright so I don't know a through the
biggest sure that's true so that's that
seems to be much yeah I think was just
playing as immediate as he can no
where's threatening Bishop F my error
sometimes are bad Bishop f7 King g7 and
now c5 and this seems kind of dangerous
on number two is starting to come yeah I
think the main threat might actually be
to play something like Bishop c4 and
you're actually preparing a rook d8 and
that's going to go like that of course
through d8 as well so many yes yeah the
Bishop e5 idea there at e8 ideas but you
know Bishop c4 obviously also attacks
are of course yes I I'm not sure what
black can do to stop these these multi
threats all coming his way
it's definitely going to be a tough well
we will see what will happen in this
game but anticipate when yes position
and definitely anticipating and Rory to
do quite well here and actually if he
wins this game he will move into first
place as well
tied with Geoffrey Zhang on one and a
half out of two and I guess some other
players might be able to join them if
they do well today as well but one and a
half out of two not a bad start to a
tournament that's true so we haven't
checked in with a B group yet why don't
we take a look I had those pairings and
see where we stand
of course we have Sergei Arenberg taking
on Alexi so uh Sorkin melech Koch ian
has drawn his game with Sergei azeroth
of course Cotchin a1 his game yesterday
after a long long day for him he did
commentary before the Sun rose and then
he kept playing chess until the sunset
that's true and he won that game I mean
what's an amazing Bishop endgame
yesterday yeah definitely well played by
him I guess he deserves a quick draw for
today to get some recovery
Frederico Perez Ponza is playing against
Justin Wang Justin of course the leader
in the B group right now
his first game against Christopher you
her root Union takes on L Shawn Marathi
Abadi and Christopher you is taking on
Emilio Cordova and what is our key
matchup for the day so this what do we
have going on here
neither of these players really in the
lead but of course very interesting
chess and you can't count Christopher
you out he he lost yesterday to the
other youngster in the tournament in
Justin white but he is definitely
looking to score some serious points in
this event and look at him how confident
he is there he was able to take a look
at the game early on and I was a little
bit surprised by Emilio Emilio Cordova's
early blunder or I don't know if it was
something he prepared or not the girl's
position we can clearly see Christopher
has to be good for like three three
extra pawns right so let us maybe go
from the beginning to see what has
happened in this game because it's
certainly very interesting and maybe not
really expected
so we have the caro-kann oh no I mean d5
Knight of 3d takes e4 Knight takes e4
Knight f6 everything seems natural so
far right I always get worried when when
it's the caro-kann and black is losing
that's true well racing up anymore
but yeah but this isn't the line I think
this is black players for sure yeah it's
not the main line so but 93 for Queen
takes e4 so in this position certainly
there can be some tricky things coming
on like when you trade this d5 pawn I
always prefer actually in this position
so we go back to 93 if I play the
CARICOM if Knight f3 I think black
should keep the pawn in d5 a little bit
longer maybe play something like g6 here
yeah there's actually let's move Knight
f6 for black this is a main choice and
after E 5 I should play Knight e4 and
then just some French style positions
but black actually gets to keep the dark
squared bishop
and instead exchanges the night for the
knight on c3 instead of you know the
normal Bishop b4 Bishop of course yeah
yeah so this is an option to if you want
to play that but there are other others
as well like it before you know g6 the
ship g4 I think is even a moon Bishop g4
I mean so many more so this a little bit
like in the way I used to play a little
bit caro-kann and and I I didn't really
like capturing and having to capturing
e4 and allowing white with this you know
Knight years of course Knight f6 can
only be natural to trade it but look
what happened here Caleb Queen d5
offering a queen trade right so of
course white does not want that is in
classic caro-kann style it's not and
actually I have seen I mean the Cordova
play in some very strong chess
tournaments and it seems to me like his
style is to play maybe some openings
that are not super theoretical but he
always seems to find some great ways to
like build up to them yeah of course the
Queen d5 not the maintenance but I was
saying it isn't that the style of the
care of condors yeah yeah thank you
Queen traded every opportunity yeah but
but of course white does not want to
trade so Queen of four and now white is
looking at this idea to play Bishop c4
develop the bishop and then try to go
for f7 right familiar checkmate threat
so surprised to see that in this
position
Amelia Cordova played Bishop f5 which I
find to be a big mistake just simply
giving up a pawn after Bishop c4 giving
up Tempe as well
Tempe too so Queenie for trying to trade
the Queen's but the problem is after
retreat the Queen's there's this
sacrifice that is temporary and now why
just plays in 95 and wins the bishop and
now we just have an extra pawn and this
is this is very confusing I'm not sure
what he missed I'm not sure what he had
prepared but this wasn't it it's
certainly very tough I he spent some
time for sure in that position probably
realizing after Bishop f5 but it's
certainly very tough when early in
game you're you're missing something you
know maybe you're having a bad day or
right it's just tough but you didn't
give up he still you know was able to
put some pressure in later in the game
but it seems like Christopher you
considering the final position that we
have or the current position we were
looking at earlier he was able to really
get ahead in the game by a lot yeah you
do kind of wonder if uh maybe age had a
factor here I think a lot of these
established grandmasters try and pick on
the young kids who are still kind of
building the repertoire
still kind of figuring out which lines
that they like the most and so he played
something you know kind of incredibly
offbeat that maybe he had hopes
Christopher hadn't had the experience
and hadn't seen yet but that's true I
made it very well and like that is
suffering the consequences that's true I
mean it makes sense I mean when you play
a kid you're thinking okay I have all
this experience right that you shouldn't
be able to know more than I do right but
I think you have to be very careful when
you actually give them material because
if it's not completely sound and you
haven't really analyzed it in depths it
yeah of course it could be devastating
so I certainly don't think he intended
to a lot of this Bishop takes f7
probably but I really like here
Christopher's idea to play h4 and then
get this rope developed through h3 kind
of taking advantage of the fact that
blacks king is not really hidden
anywhere and just this is a nice
development you don't need to to Casa
because well there are no Queens on the
board anymore but this is a really nice
way to get your rook into play and this
is actually something that just in
wearing did against him the other day we
reckon eight so maybe wait no he still
did that Rican no note was his game but
he ended up playing croquet six himself
it's up where so maybe this is something
that likes to do sometimes when he has
the ability to bring the hooks into the
game so I do want to mention you know
there are some positions where it feels
like one side is up upon but you know
they've lost time to take it and then
the other side starts to build up some
kind of initiative but here the pawn is
actually really really
if blacks still had a pawn on f7 things
like the g5 squared wouldn't be so weak
the g6 square wooden pieces a week but
with this pawn missing these are gonna
be very very sore spots for the black
King and white pieces can jump into g5
this is gonna put pressure on g6 and and
there's really nowhere to hide and of
course this pawn also weak with honey F
pawn and there's a pond down and black
doesn't really have advantage in
development so White's more developed
has the safer King has more pawns has
less weaknesses it's looking quite good
yes and let's see how so 95 the King had
to go to g8 now okay we're not too
worried about blacks looking in nature
because it can come into play this way
but still it's a little bit unpleasant
do you three Roky 894 okay yeah so now
you are making sure your Minh you're
keeping blocks 1987 because of this very
long thread so if you want to do
something with black you need to move
the king so look at that king it's moved
you know going to g6 back to do you need
now back getting in his exercise well
which probably should have other pieces
you know Knight of 6 and okay so now
Christopher is just making natural
development moves and look f1 okay so
he's probably maybe you're thinking
something like a 4 although that's not
really something I would do seems a
little ambitious saying I feel yeah he's
trying to kill his opponent that's that
yeah but then I'm not really necessary
he's changing he's basically just
placing his rook on the same phallus
like skiing to kind of annoying huge you
seem a little bit 92 so now maybe he's
going for 94 trying to put some pressure
good and finally bringing this looking
to play so looks like that pawn could be
falling very soon so now g4 since the
only and you can really see the
difference here with the extra pawn why
it's fun enough to is actually very very
important the white bishop on g5 can
never be chased away because there's no
have fun yes but for white f3 is always
gonna be a knob
and this night will not stay on gene for
know that night is not another pasta we
should make it red because it will be
chasing not right now not right now of
course because we need to go to protect
our broken the pawn first and then we'll
we'll see when it's the right moment to
chase it away b5 of course our 19 c4
wasn't on an outpost either but now as
the ponds get to be pushed some
weaknesses are going to be created so
another Knight can come to e4 and try to
go towards that square no there he's
doing it all right so he changed his
mind he's not going to do 95 because
probably just to check so now he goes 93
having some little threat over here
taking the knight and the pawn one more
pawn you know and it seems like he did
it because there's no clear way for
black to defend maybe g6
yeah g6 feels a little testy something
with F work would work maybe not yeah
I'm not really seeing it after after 4
maybe maybe D for Steve for I will take
it yeah maybe there isn't a tactical
refutation but it might have just been
time to let the pawn go
there's also possibly a Bishop h6 move
and then if this rook goes to f7 now
maybe there's f4 ideas yeah sure I
really would like to go back 94 but the
knight is there so I mean you could take
it and bring your knight back to the
outposts but I'm not sure if that's what
he had in mind but it seems like black
decided to give up another pawn maybe
thinking from gauge 6 will try to get
some counter play but g4 and now g6 is
not possible I wonder if that's what
black had in mind cuz maybe this was
this was missed something must have been
missed something must have been yeah
it's like you really can't afford to
give up a second oh that's just sore
sure not the end of the game and now d4
yeah it seems like Christopher's he's
got his game let's let's catch up with
the current position
he's probably yeah he's yeah not too
much more to say that pawn that pawn is
just going down and then look at how
many postpones we have and there's not
so much to do
Bishop h6 rope d4 and let's see if any
moves did I miss anything by this book
so I'm sorry no wrong game alright so
they played a few more moves after our
final position and so we do have a
result
Grigoriy oprand has actually managed to
complete the victory against the bonus
caboose Ian's so grigory moving into
shared first place in the a group with
the one and only Jeffrey Zhang born of
course a very strong player from the
Mizzou chess team which is get getting
started in this past year but oh and it
looks like this game has ended as well
all right Chris you shaking hands with
Amelia we might ask one of them to join
us and maybe both yeah I'm sure this
would be some great interviews to get
grigory I know has some very good
performances recently she won one of
these Invitational events right maybe
the you know I actually can't remember
oh go ahead but I also know he actually
had a chance I think to compete in the
World Cup
he didn't advance too far and that I
think he also went out to - isle of man
as well so yeah grigory the Globetrotter
he's he's making his rounds on the
professional chess circuit and it's good
to have him here in st. Louis showing
what he can do yeah great game is played
so well we get a Gregorian Christopher
down here for an interview possibly what
other games struck he was interesting
well I was surprised a little bit I have
to say about Jeffrey's younger against
Sam 7 that's Rob this is the final
position that they had what why I was
surprised is because we have
Jeffrey here yesterday and he came to
show us he's great he seemed like you
know he didn't do anything it just
seemed like he played just so confident
and everything when he's way yeah but
first today he actually he's changed the
line remember how yesterday after Knight
takes c6 B takes c6 he went for this
Bishop g3 line today well we we don't
have him here anymore to ask anyway I
believe he probably is maybe getting
ready for next game already about human
45 knots you know from the main line
that's interesting to see you know
wonderful
you know Sam maybe did something he
didn't like when he was looking at
something this Bishop d3 lines possible
or many ways that was he thought Sam
might have prayed for him and so it's
possible and yeah he wanted to change
but I was told in general of course you
know everyone has their own ways but if
you are winning in an opening you
shouldn't change it although that's
usually applies to the same players if
you end up playing against someone that
you keep beating them at the same
opening you should not change it exactly
but um okay here's a little bit
different so alright so let's see what
else what other interesting games we had
we can move maybe this is interesting
from the B group Sergei Lemberg against
Alexei Sorokin Black has more pawns yeah
I like it you want to see a lot of
decisive decisive events I guess Kayla I
think we actually have Grigory here
ready to come into the studio
that's quite a really quick go in for an
interview yeah so this is a very
interesting position hmm when I left
when I went upstairs to check out the
games it seemed like this might be it
was pretty equal but now it has changed
so maybe we can all right hmm
I certainly not sure what has happened
let's go few moves back okay so white
has lost that pawn a long time ago
mm-hmm King f8 Bishop g5 all right so we
have Gregorio parting after a really
awesome win today congratulations thanks
for joining us
would you like to take us through your
game all right I have a very interesting
move I have found with the help of the
computer earlier so I'll ask your
opinion about it you don't mind
I checked actually checks this 94 is
this morning for two minutes uh-huh so
what are you expecting for instance
Jamie's Indian so 94 is it is one of the
moves
yeah I just checked it for a few minutes
so he was good it's always great when
you prepare last minute and then your
opponents are playing that it's okay so
Queen c2 and 92 seem natural to get
really yeah before they point 93 here
but after night sweet no I mean Queen c2
F F okay Knight c3 Knight takes c3 I
think black he's okay here so yeah
because if you take with the Queen may
be safe - yeah so 92 is probably yeah SH
more testing option yeah - and you do
this in in a lot you can do it in
opening stakes takes Bishop before
Loki 851 Queen f6
you should see I had this patient during
my preparation it's like we're two
slightly but better already here yeah
because these pieces development yeah so
do you think maybe boy is nice to six
I'll go before all right
mmm-hmm just chase the night guys it's
it seemed to be tougher black I wasn't
sure maybe e5 is not the typical mo for
black to play in that position maybe but
if not he fives and I'm just slightly
better by t4 maybe at some point I can
avoid bishops III
and then you also have before me yeah
okay so you got this position Queen e7
and I really like this this idea before
I think it has to wear for cause
otherwise he'll just take on a fight if
I yeah dude would you would you rush to
take an f5 or maybe played okay one for
what's a knight c6 yeah of course I can
play Luke you keep on saying after year
for it's just a transposition to the
game but I can also take on a5 yeah
that's if he takes with chip owner I can
have Knight h4 maybe and maybe later
yeah it does look right for work because
you should be still on see agent yeah
you'd love this bishop to somehow come
and go to f7 for sure yeah therefore and
then you took took me five it's very
risky for bad because uh-huh I have is
exclaming some point yeah
for example my next move might be issues
yeah here yeah
so he played Bishop e6 you can't Bishop
a5 but Quinn Berry
op8
and maybe even a six here because I have
piece of edges after Bishop takes c6
yeah and h4 what are you scared at all
like trying to play it foreign we can
little bit your Kings side to play 95
and stuffer I think is kind of a
standard I did I started before yeah and
there is no way to defend against
Nigeria because 86 just weekends g6 he
had to play it eventually but it's just
in like his position was destroyed I
meant forces bishop d5 but actually I
was rude because I had Bishop f3 just
did you want to train eeeh just go from
a position of way it takes I would take
the knight way Queenie for all right
yeah and this pawn is going to be very
weak here yeah so we can continue f3 and
then here h6 I liked your queen b7 I was
surprised by the 8th I thought he'll
take on g5 but you're going to she takes
it for I was going to play pinkish one
my bishop on d5 is just dominating my
next move d4 I think ah okay Bishop d4
Bishop found like that so maybe Queen c5
you just want to go for the end game you
should be much better for you alright so
he played OB 8 and then Chris is 6 and
here you know I was watching the game a
little bit and I love this move what do
you think about it
yes I haven't checked in depth but I
just thought it was you know of course
you're completely winning a we really
enjoyed your your game but I think it's
just like you're trading everything yeah
it just looks nice I don't know I was so
happy but a queen a for else of course
you're you're forcing the trade and then
the endgame you're I think completely
winning right I mean Queen III is
probably just resigns you should have
quite c5 just to keep the Queen so
aboard still she's a queen abortions I
think has more choices sure yeah yeah
after Queens art I guess could just
needs to be should pay five yeah and
then because you're taking a c7 and then
you have Bishop d6 for forking in this
position yeah just over here yes yeah
there is no way he can stop my boss yeah
we really enjoyed your game what are
your thoughts going into this event are
you he said I think you've won one of
them right like maybe you're trying to
win this yeah I wanna subscribe well I
think I have some decent chances yeah
seven rebounds two goals anything can
happen
yeah of course it's it's a tough one
this is just round two but we appreciate
you coming here thank you drew so much
for walking us through our game and we
wish you good luck in the future and
thank you thank you all right that was
great game so excited about Queen f6 he
was very excited to so that's great
let's see some other game while we're
getting Christopher you in here in the
studio
what are there interesting oh this was a
promising game Wow I thought black was
much better and look what we have here
hmm
we should definitely
get back into this to analyze this game
with Caleb but first we have Christopher
you joining us here congratulations what
what a great game you had today did you
expect your opponent's what your
opponent has done no no like I had
looked at this I would I think it's two
two nights I think it's two nights
uh-huh variation before at home so
obviously he wasn't expecting it but I
still I still so I still think I knew
more than him in the opening but this
should not be a theory right he I mean
Bishop a5 is not serious yes up until
this point is series yes queen of five
seems more natural I wasn't exactly sure
I know d3 is not a bad move you can even
play Queenie free but leave free white
probably has a very slight advantage
mm-hmm so just you you just don't want
to take to help him develop the pieces
or play d3 wait for him to take then you
capture back with them also possible
besides d3 is Queenie free I don't know
it very well I looked at it before but I
didn't remember what - it's a pawn
sacrifice he takes on c2 you have to
know very well what you're doing here
but I know that it's eagle but I don't
actually know what to do so I wouldn't
that point being free yeah yeah you
should go for what - no stop seeing I've
a vague we looked at just briefly yeah
so you would have probably gone for
something more safe just yeah if you
don't know you should yeah sounds good
so then when your opponent played Bishop
f5 did you spend a lot of time in this
position you know I didn't spend that
much time I just played I don't looked
at Bishop c4 I just double check to see
what in the world does my opponent have
I think you're just winning a pawn yeah
I checked just a few minutes they
decided okay okay maybe you just missed
Queen c5 before oh okay yeah we didn't
look at that move but yeah that's me
there's nothing really else to look at
Queenie I was the same scene Queen d7 I
can take on their seven of course yeah
you can do the same thing and so did she
spend a lot of time here and he really I
mean yeah he's been he's been like maybe
like eight ten minutes just thinking but
I mean he really has no choice
yeah this is very tough when once you
blunder in the opening it just it's very
tough to come back and then I really
enjoyed the way you play the game
afterwards I tell taking I really
enjoyed your your age for trying to get
your rook out this way it was kind of a
cool idea I was hoping I was glad I hit
by age five I know that because she
weakens a lot of a lot of squares that's
true but what I know we want you to
prevent like age five but I'm thinking
maybe mens are six maybe but maybe you
can just play 97 king of seven maybe
from a practical viewpoint this is hard
harder for me just a try King of seven I
have a lot of questions what should i do
should I put age six now I should
everybody free first maybe do three one
right up six maybe you can just develop
this fish up where do it let's go for h6
them big six just g6 Bishop g5 player
Bishop e7 I guess here maybe walk is
losing a pawn
maybe Knight takes e4 and then Bishop
the question is does the h6 pawn really
help well in summer in games it can be
helped it can't be helped I mean the
king of pawn I think it should be at the
same time like white is not getting the
D file and stuff so I'm not sure
whoa no I'm pretty sure there's a better
way to play after Knight d7 but that's
not exactly obvious so from a practical
viewpoint maybe maybe you don't play h5
maybe playing h5 is not really helping
and just let that pawn there maybe you
can do everywhere white of course is
gonna be much valuable yeah it's not
easy - yeah so your opponent kind of
started creating some weaknesses himself
which was which was helpful for you of
course he should try to figure out a
good setup for the pawns and this h5 is
kind of weakening a lot especially you
know he's and I wanted to ask you this I
noticed you did something like this
yesterday in your yesterday's game or
the Lucases do you like this kind of
idea SpaceX was not a good I know I know
it was a good I know I know but do you
usually like to get your your rook into
games this is just the coincidence this
is not like some we'll see we'll see or
maybe maybe new games but it's a cool
idea right all right so 97 I guess it's
not a mistake but I was more worried
about Bishop e7 to control g5 mm-hmm I
guess here I can do similar plan d3
Knight d7 it's hard to say if trading
the bishop for my knight is a good trade
or not maybe not I would probably think
the trade the bishops but that's me
that's me but whatever you try to trade
the bishop C is Knight of 6 mm-hmm so
you can't really create the bishops
easily I know maybe you can go something
like this
being up 7
maybe some f3 oh but can it be a 395
[Music]
yeah of course of course again why I
mean okay I guess Bishop takes d5 third
and I take so into the night of king of
sex I guess nightmare 494 the e5 pawn
yeah this is always going to be any case
you're definitely having a great maybe
you can cause some longer and then get
your new looking to play I mean there's
there's lots of things you can do or get
worse it's tough but sometimes you need
your opponent's help to change things
and from here it seemed kind of it went
smoothly for ya murky yet again I I
don't he's allowing me to point 94
Bishop g5 yeah he maybe didn't realize
to when to trade pieces and then it
seemed like maybe after Castle in a few
moves here I like to ride Erica for
maybe were you playing to play for here
yeah yeah and then you're like is that I
wasn't when you play King e6 I was
wondering if I rectify move wasn't good
I realize oh if I ever eat one and the
King on e6 is it yeah so he actually
helped you it seems like a little bit
because then he goes to d7 but the key
now I can't do for my Knight to c4 yeah
yeah and around here let's just go a
little bit ahead like in this position
do you think he just blundered
the pawn de-spawn here in nature I think
he tried to do that on purpose I think
he might've missed Bishop takes f6 G
takes f6 Knight takes a try or gay kv-4
okay five who maybe he missed everything
oh okay I thought maybe he missed him
the other one after okay six G for the
way the game happened maybe he missed g6
he couldn't play just six years cousin I
yeah so I see but what else does he
really have have to do well yeah but he
maybe doesn't need to give the protocol
six is the way to go yeah yeah you go
Bishop h6 baby I don't know I don't like
this I don't see the point
I there the main question is should I
take tonight or not it's not an easy
question it's not it's not you know not
often want to give up your night
we are Bishop for a night but this
Bishop is pretty please I know but the
main player vows over if I can win defy
or tag Jesus you can to touch it's very
concrete so it's hard to say yes or no
mm-hmm if you if you somehow could get
your knight enough tree would be
greatest pigheaded there may be night if
one bring it even if the knight warned
that free just Knight g4 yeah but then
you know you can see when you're going
to take this night and then get your
night or three maybe I mean it's not so
your night is already on F free and you
haven't taken the 994 and then you can't
see when you can take denies no here I
can take here yeah 94 I think I don't
think the night is ideal on after E I
mean I guess that's just her supporter
but you're not even threatening me five
because the f2 power will be you want it
on an active score like c5 and then d4
mm-hm
maybe you can play some truck
preparatory moves like g3 mm-hmm to
guard some squares I got four maybe sure
then maybe you leave this maybe you can
just play d4 immediately without any
preparation yeah you have to do
something something there at some point
all right well but your opponent blunder
after dad to seem like yes a great game
yeah well we are really happy to see you
like Ray chess especially today we wish
you good luck in your quest of you want
to become a grandmaster I believe right
so how many norms you have zero zero yet
but you're trying here very hard right
all right well we wish you good luck
with that we hope to see more
interesting games of yours and yeah
thank you for coming here
Thanks
all right so let us see what other
changes have happened there were some
decisive results Oh Nelson has lost
that's going to be a tough night all
right so I think we're going to have a
harder to nyan join us very soon this is
the final position maybe
Elson hasn't chosen the best opening but
well let her to nyan walk us through the
game later some other I don't believe we
have had other results yet verse is
harutunian going to join us possibly we
don't know we don't know yet all right
so let's go back to maybe this game so
this was certainly something very
strange happening in this game white is
upon down who's going to try very best
to hold on to the position I believe
this might be very tough caleb is
joining me yes the second I'm back in
for just a few moments well alright
makes his way down the steps of the
Chess Club it is a long journey for some
yeah but yeah it looks as though looking
at here oh I remember I just was looking
through the games at some point I came
across this one and watches upon down
just yeah this seems like yeah tough
tough game to defend for white looks
what does have an active rook at least
maybe some holding chances but
it is looking very very tough for sure
yeah another game day so it was
interesting unless you wanted to look at
one specific no yeah I just wanted to
mention what an interview from from
Christopher you full of confidence at
such a young age yeah it's fun to see
him play chess and be you know so
confident in his ideas yeah yeah and he
knows he's analyzing his games
immediately knows if he has made a good
move bad move in another game you know
it's great that they get the chance to
do that some coaches actually tell their
players not to analyze their games
during the tournament because it can
affect your thinking about the game way
too much the goal that just happened but
I don't know I think especially as
they're you know growing in their chess
careers every game is a learning
experience
of course days they just get better
every time they play and so it's
important for them to see those games
yeah as quickly as possible yeah yes so
you were gonna mention this game yes
because this game before we went live I
was looking at it and I thought black
was much better so I'm a little bit
surprised to see that white has upon up
I mean yes maybe you can go back around
maybe move 10 somewhere around here it's
just normal
opening kind of cars bone structure oh
yeah Black has played D takes CT takes
e4 yeah then expanded on the queenside
looking your play moves like c5 to
challenge this yeah yeah this is this is
the typical idea that black wants to do
just play c5 and try to open up the
bishop then they will just get these two
pawns traded off the board that's great
and then we have a very similar if we
have a symmetrical pawn structure and in
this case black has the pair of bishop
so that should be create for them
of course though why does have the
center and for the moment can play some
tempo moves like e5 yes so this is
natural but sometimes you have to be
careful on how fast you're pushing the
pawns forward because right now White
has a control over all of these four
squares right so if you push one you
give up the d5 square and if black
manages to get the piece there it could
be
very annoying so you sometimes want to
wait a little bit longer for touch but
it seems like a victory judgment for a
five immediately and then my gratuity 28
of course that's very natural because
eventually you know the Queen doesn't
stay so great in f6 you need to retreat
and now Queen e4 and this move a little
bit surprised me why did it surprise you
well of course you have this kind of
ideas right black is not castled yet and
then you're just placing your queen on
the discovery of the C pawn so that
doesn't seem to be such a great idea for
for--why to do you know like it's just
kind of tough I think so yeah it was a
bit surprising to me because with this
move e5 and the trade of the dark
squared Bishop I think white is really
looking to control the dark squares or
the bonds and yes and Queenie for just
doesn't isn't really in line with that
mm-hmm even a move like Queen III would
make a lot more sense to me guarding
some dark squares yeah I think though my
time here is short once again I think a
route Union is just about ready to come
in for his interview I once again will
be stepping out and we will hear from
him on his game against I'll Shawn
maratti abadi sure meanwhile let's look
at this game on service Oh Queen e4
certainly not very ideal for whites here
placing the Queen on the c5 pawn push
and then black played Queen b6 of course
now getting ready for the c5 and here
again big surprise to me it was the fact
that White Castle long yes you took us
along sometimes but here it just seems a
little bit too much for y to just think
that everything is going to be great and
then 97 king b1 Bishop before this
position just seems super great for
black rook c1 and then c5 just you know
just chasing the Queen away which wasn't
supposed to be placed on a light square
in the first place in my opinion and
okay we don't know exactly what has
happened
but we have there must
Union here to welcome in the studio
thanks for joining us Congrats on your
way today would you like to walk us
through your game and the preparation so
did you did you expect
no okay
we're so what are you prepared I know
c63 so this is this is a very stilted
theory all the weights on here rain 97
night h4 you know thinking uh-huh maybe
not know one of the main ways yes okay
don't remember maybe okay yeah for
seemed interesting is not interesting at
five and you're kind of forcing black
person to play a Fife and if that
happens the bishops just dead here in g6
so aged five Kings boy
mmm-hmm so of course you don't want to
play five here because then so just go
back and then that's right
something in there seriously yeah and
then this one is going to do way so
you're not rushing King g7
Bishop g7 or Bishop e6 I didn't say 505
935 can you find Bishop f5 uris oh wait
here uh-huh
should be six for example five takes
takes and then you should be six
Bishop easy I see okay all right so so
the bishop is not here because the
bishop okay I see the difference okay so
that's why you played it straight okay
so you're kind of waiting for black to
see where they place the bishop
basically not to allow maybe but you
still play g4 and this is probably not
really such a great idea
take g4 i have 96 an idea check
yeah the pros they cannot play a five
again i wish i was played by it's not
possible
alright so he kind of had to take take
[Music]
okay and now he's coming trying to
improve the position of his knight a
little bit but just starting to control
these squares yeah because they are
attracting maybe these six not to let
you there and then this would be a
weakness right I want to play here a 95
takes taking the 94 and then then that
night is going to have some trouble
mm-hmm so what do you think where do you
think of like I made a mistake
I cannot see it might be nice yet so
maybe we should just kind of wait here
in this position or just try to go take
the night yeah I mean this Bishop is is
kind of tough that that the f4 is
forcing f5 just kills this bishop if you
don't manage to get the bishop in the
game surely all right so let's let's see
so you he ended up just giving the
bishop and now ninety four hear you play
troops in one right so he thought to
just sacrifice the pawn to to try to get
some country play with the route but
probably wasn't enough what what were
you playing after maybe I can just go
back takes takes Knight you see and you
enter from the other side takes and then
location yeah but maybe black and have
some chances to right got rid of that
bad bishop yeah was but maybe you can
try so yeah take a seat
mm-hmm so loop d8 and you can take on b2
696
yeah doesn't seem like black and stop
that and the bishop is not really
running mm-hmm
yeah that's that's also like going for
the mate okay so just creating the
weakness first but then life before it
takes look she said yeah or maybe it'll
cook e7 some night their threes coming
yeah alright so Wow doesn't seem so save
the king there I mean but you can't just
get this rook there if you could that
would be amazing
[Music]
can you play something like a four here
already six now before I see
kind of dangerous this is not clear okay
so after before just the keying probably
just students didn't make it in there
okay just did I want to play yeah this
opponents going there's nothing to do
huh nice game thank you thank you for
for joining us we thank you we wish you
good luck for the next next games and
not so much but I know I'm joking but we
wish you good luck for the next rounds
and we hope to see you again
I guarantee next rounds thanks all right
tough loss for Elgin I'm not I don't
know I I'm thankful I'm still here and
to be longer so caleb is going to join
me in a second then we are going to
check out a little bit maybe the
pairings and the results that have
happened so far in the a and B group I
think it'll be great to kind of let all
of you know the recent things happening
in the tournament
hopefully you're also staying on track
online I'm back I don't have to work too
hard today interviews but yeah we do
have just left in the show here so we
can still look at a couple games made
yeah sure sure knowing us just to give
you the verbal rundown in the B group we
have two games still in progress
Christopher you has won his game against
the
Cordova Christopher rebounding after a
tough loss in round one
- Justin wing root Union of course we
just saw managed to win his game against
el shamah radhiya body and lastly Koch
Ian I actually drew his game against
Sergey Azeroth early on today now I
wanted to mention something about that
actually many kuchen he actually had
double White's so in a ways you know
maybe good for him to relax after
yesterday's win with white now he gets
another wide so yes but that just means
more blacks later to come in the tree
that's it that's true so you know you
you get to relax now but later you'll
make it tougher wishing you got a couple
points and in the a group we have two
games that finished a great Oberyn has
won his game against savannas kuboos Ian
the former tournament leader and
Geoffrey Zhang had a quick draw against
Sam seven earlier today so a lot of
chess still to be played what's going on
in the a group does anybody have chances
to catch the co-leaders a Gregorian
Geoffrey well earlier like before I
interviewed before I went on to
interview I was discussing this game a
little bit
if you remember we were kind of stuck
around here with the queen bee in the
center and suddenly you know when we go
from this position where it seems like
black is going to be the one attacking
White's King to suddenly yeah and black
has in castled yet so they they don't
need to castle they can wait a little
bit longer and even if they do like of
course they will if eventually about
yeah it just seems like black is having
this really great position and even if
White has some ideas bringing in the
night to 2d6 I don't know like I really
enjoy enjoy blacks position here what
are you thinking them yeah the bishops
look nice the bishop on b7 is very
active the bishop on b4 actually
controls some dark squares around the
King as well as well both Kings actually
yeah and just a very natural queen side
attack and I don't really see the extra
point for black yeah that's actually
yeah although sometimes in these kinds
of
positions white sometimes gives up that
deep on and eventually will recapture it
but here it seems like it went from it's
a powerful attacker actually the c3
square no longer available sure yeah so
I don't know let's let's play through
the game and see like Bishop d6 tonight
c5 I think black is just kind of
consolidating now so sure yeah actually
an extra bond so how could how could it
happen
I went from a pawn up to a pawn down
that doesn't seem okay the endgame most
likely will finish in a draw but still
like okay so why this is taking
advantage of this hook in h6 going g4 g5
trying to open up the G file oh is you
look for the puns that have moved in
front of your opponent's king that's the
corner can latch on to that's like an
open files and then black has decided to
take this bishop which I would take as
well just make sure to get through them
the bishop so that there's no attack
anymore but and any any g5 can be met
with h5 a lot of the time so maybe I
think j6 sometimes it works but maybe
not here maybe Bishop e7 would be yeah
this doesn't believe a black chose to
represent yeah okay try to strengthen
the control over the g5 square so you
can't do that but white is preparing it
again so hopefully Bishop e7 wasn't
mistake i I don't know where the mistake
went we haven't we haven't looked at
this game there's so many so many moves
that have happened so now okay it seems
like if black is going for an endgame of
course white doesn't want to trade so
now okay now I can see how white we
captured their pawn yeah I'm not sure
where the mistake was but g5 is on the
verge of coming 95 also he's an idea
just sacrificing the night opening up to
each file going for h7 for sure
you know it feels like the piece that's
really missing for black might be that
light square bishop maybe Bishop takes
e4 was played a little
hastily maybe dowas if we go back to
this position stops from 94 maybe I mean
it just leave that it is a very active
night of course but I mean it's castles
I think this is certain for it for black
here maybe not maybe you can just give
up that pawn but also I didn't expect 94
you know I was expecting something I
just take the pawn you know and then I
can house right and then have fun but 94
it is a very typical I don't know why I
didn't consider it in the beginning
hmm maybe just maybe even Bishop dd5 is
an idea and you're looking for things
like Queen a5 the question is like do
you care about the g7 pawn that's the
question that you have to alert yeah
for example I thought I might you can
not take it yet you know what maybe we
can go Queenie 5 versus you cannot take
it because then we take the nitrogen
check - yeah but then I was trying to
make some useful moves I don't need to
move the bishop play I don't think
you're gonna you're gonna take my pawn
yeah so Bishop d5 seems kind of
interesting here yeah obviously I guess
and what something like this would not
be very ideal for white because this
would be the hook yeah so we're going
back and then maybe even to f8 you want
to go directly I just okay I guess ya
know why not I mean we have an extra
pawn I mean he should be able to take it
like anytime like oh wait if I take
maybe 96 b5 yeah
so yeah let's go to my feet and then
you're ready for the break I just I
don't really like giving up that
LightSquared bishop yeah that was
actually doing it's it's a powerful
attacker if you consent to d5 and it
kind of holds the white pieces back a
little bit yeah
understandable one in the year that that
strong night but then yeah I guess the
game kind of just just turned from there
right yeah you started turning right now
white is just going you know we we've
seen these moves already you can just go
through it fast rook c8 look C to D one
now trading everything anything just
getting ready for g5 and now 95 the move
the move that changes things a little
bit of course you cannot take we can
know I'd go for something like this and
don't think that g6 will say because
nope and then you have a check and
that's it there's no back fragment I've
seen this one before yeah I mean I I've
done this before but then I had the mate
just unfortunate it like would not have
that so they had to go for Bishop takes
Knight and now they took an e5 alright
but now now blacks King seems to be in
danger of course you don't want to
recapture in age six his rook takes and
then mmm they're annoying so g5 a little
bit of danger but I think a lot no
because the other look is coming well
okay well I mean I'm not taking that pun
okay after Jenna right after g5 oh I
thought you meant too tentative that to
take an 86
oh no never you know the H pun works for
you
so now white is finally capturing their
pawn down and we're getting into a
routine game where suddenly it seems
like white is doing pretty good like
this pawn here is going to be very
annoying because you cannot win it
immediately if you could win it a little
unconvinced actually what if I play a
keen age 7 and just king g6 and then
then you
it's not going so far I wonder if f4 is
an option before I can I even just take
it mm-hmm I will play King g6 and I want
to play g5 but probably not good oh it
looks like officially yeah that's what
do we expect it for dunya
it just was a little bit surprised cuz
you know white seem to be doing worsen
okay saving is good sure yeah I guess
the black approach the endgame a little
bit differently but yeah he decided to
just trade I mean I don't think blacks
should be too worried about losing a
position like this because they have
such a good pawn structure yeah I mean
a6 is a weakness but in a lot of cases
are given if you lose that pawn and I
mean it's as soon as the rook goes to
collect then the H pawn falls so this
game I guess a fair result then and yeah
wait somehow I managed to navigate
pretty well for sure yeah they they came
up with some great great to typing ideas
okay there is one game I want to take a
look at but yes of course what's going
on between Sethu and Jim abaya let's
check that out do not manage us to win
this game he will move into joint first
place and he does have more rooks but he
does what so it's tricky when you have
an exchange up because you need to make
sure your rooks get active otherwise
can't do so much I mean white is well
placed with the bishop but this pawn in
d5 is going to be very dangerous if
black manages to trade a pair of rooks I
think they should have no trouble thank
you
well I think white has made it the right
right yeah d4 being a being threatened
to win this d5 pawn probably so what can
we do about it is there any way to stop
such a move I don't I don't see it I
just want to go back a few moves just as
we see how those rooks get over there so
why play d4 alright so black has tried
to kind of challenge that rooking d8 it
doesn't feel the most natural to me well
he's trying to get well the rook layer
is protected so you're trying to trade
it make sure it's not protected right
and route d7 I wonder if black had
thought about going maybe King e6 and
then try to push the D pawn but then
they were like no no no but yeah they
cannot give up too much material it is
maybe maybe actually giving away too
much I wouldn't say trying to lose but
it is giving away some connected passed
pawns so now why didn't go back to the
8th they went to d6 oh there's tickling
that's this is thread that we can have
which much for short Bishop d4 kind of
going for that poem but also going for
the a6 pawn right I don't know how I
made that white well I just invented
than you think invented a new color
white is red so is there anything better
for black there must be we have more
rough I mean why does have a little bit
more time so but we're not really like
the time just they just got their
additional 30 minutes right so I think
sure my baby's taking his time in this
position and making sure there's nothing
better right because you know when you
pass the time control you should always
make sure you know what the evaluation
of the position is before you make any
decisions like drastically okay let's
make a draw or something absolutely
so well okay what happens if we play
rookie six and I guess just yeah or room
da because I believe the rook was in d8
in the beginning like oh sure right
wasn't gonna play rook e8 my idea is
once you check me I
do you want to go for did you just run
it maybe he's calculating dad so let's
see what happens here this seems like
the critical try the problem is you
cannot push it immediately that's why
I'm kind of yes I'm not sure I want to
go for this line well I don't have to
give you all my pawns maybe I can play
Ricci 7 and try and keep your rook a
little bit out of the game I'm sure for
how long
rook d7 hmm now I'm now I'm coming for
you all right yeah I'm pushing on push
can i push yeah I want to believe huh do
we have anything do we or not I don't
see how I stand upon somebody else too
greedy going for the nape on I shouldn't
go for the day pawn I think this
actually looks kind of promising for
black maybe this is this is the way to
go okay I shouldn't go you know I was
over optimistic so you go King King e6
I'll take maybe you can go for my a pawn
immediately seems like you can still
kind of do this Oh but now when I take
it I hope discovering yeah maybe I have
to maybe I have to play d4
and if you take my pond I'll take your a
pond mm-hmm so you're trying to get the
fritter but then you're giving this one
a lot but if you take on g7 that I still
have like Rick a8 and I'm getting behind
the pond and I think that's yeah but
I'll have three pawns that's the thing
but I guess I have all the time I think
I really believe in the rest
Rick d5 maybe and I'll start going
I agree should it should be good but you
definitely have to have a good sense of
evaluating this position before you go
for it because it's well they're not my
pond size of course of course it's
always so much easier when it's not your
game
I did that all the time I shouldn't like
has actually played rook d7 oh they did
so after rookie seven rook t6 rook d7
all right so he's trying to make sure Y
do not have the access but oh so he
wants maybe King seven well there's
there's bishop deport right that was the
problem you're trying to say yeah yeah
yeah but lightning you want to try to
see if you have a progress anything in
the position well what's happening on on
Bishop you oh great now those my
questions this is the movie we're trying
to stop last tune was thinking he wants
to is it simply ricky six rook beef fine
but then i wonder if i hmm
if i can try something new districts
attract some of these pawns to push you
do you want them further apart
well this F porn probably trying to take
advantage of their King but I'm not sure
I'm not sure if it's really because you
can also just take right right so I
thought so yeah maybe maybe Ricky six
you didn't wanna take it no no my no to
five is not so great
rookie five there's none of that but I
don't know maybe on Chapter seven I
wanted to block it mm-hmm I don't know
it's definitely this is the the game to
look out for once again of Jummah by of
wins this game he'll move into joint
first with Grigory Oprah and in
Jefferies on the last game maybe we can
just peek for it for just a moment see
what's going on with vari Kobe and
Daniel Mary did scheme that was out
looks at this game oh it actually looks
quite nice for white at first glance
here but at the black Bishop no not so
many squares to go to it looks really
nice and they have a pun down and have
to point it out yes that's not important
that's I didn't point it out to say it's
important it's not important because
look at the badly placed pieces of
blacks right all of them pretty passive
yes bar deciding recipes at first glance
white White's winning yeah yeah yeah it
seems great and then we have I do
tonight of six as well hmm
yeah so this one looking good for far so
good day for a bar bouncing back after
that unfortunate rather perhaps yeah
they'll be good maybe you can just a
prediction for the remaining runs and
there we can just tell everyone the
standings and where we are up yet to and
so we're expecting black to do quite
well in the circuit Erin Borg and Sorkin
game yes still one up for black and
whites King is still kind of struggling
over in the back rank and it looks like
it's going to be tough but yeah white is
actually up a few ponds in the Frederico
points a game so oh that one should be
easily winning
Justin white manages to pull off
something incredible here yeah wise king
a safe said this should be should be
pretty good yeah the only idea maybe we
could have here was trying to think for
some opposite color bish opinion but
that's very hard to imagine obstacle
Bishops three pawns is yeah there's a
lot of pause yeah well I think that's
about it for us why don't we take a look
and see where we actually stand our
games today
Geoffrey Jean of course had a quick drop
in Sam seven still securing a spot in
the leadership position with one and a
half points out of two you're Rory
Oberon won his game bring him into joint
first as well with one and a half of
honest unfortunately lost today after
round one very nice win Sam seven Alexis
Tirana
and Victor eros all drawing their games
Rinat Jim abaya is the one we have our
eye on for today he might possibly win
that game we expect bringing him into
the leadership position as well Daniel
Meredith's key is struggling against VAR
o Cobian and of our wins today he'll be
back on track after that round one yeah
and of course sethu is doing doing
poorly again I'm not Juma bias
yeah so am I my start of the tournament
but you have some chances to hold on
that position so you have to wait and
see well unfortunately we will not be
here but hopefully people at home are
watching of course why don't we take a
look at the the B group as well see
where we stand
Mel Akashi and one of the leaders drew
his game today bring him to one and a
half take her on her route Union catches
Koch in with one and a half points
Sergei azeroth and drew his game
Christopher you getting back on the
board after a tough loss around once
adjusted wing he now defeats his
opponent Emilio Cordova Justin Wang is
struggling against frederique fret
federico poncy sometimes federico of
course hoping to get to one and a half
points and join the leaders and alexei
Sorokin is doing quite well against
sergei Ehrenberg
hoping to win with an extra pawn
although it will be a long game I'm
accessor yes and that leaves us with
those standings and so Sabino any
thoughts on today's games uh it was a
tough game some interesting combination
that queen of six for a powering up so
glad yes so it's some crazy and some
crazy moves of course I'm a little bit
sad about Al Shean lost stuff when you
have to comment on your your partner
that you know you're what to do away
it's a very interesting tournament I'm
glad that we have some decisive results
and it's always great for people who are
watching us because you know you know
you you want to see fighting chess and
they think we certainly have seen that
so far yeah some very impressive chess
as well Christopher you not letting that
loss get him down and he actually
bounces back yeah oh very confident very
very convincingly
as well a very nice game by him and well
I think that's about it for us thank you
guys so much for joining us here on
YouTube as always you can follow the
games live for yourself on us chess
chance comm round three will be tomorrow
at 3:30 p.m.
unfortunately I am unable to make it oh
no that's great news for the viewers
because you actually get the wonderful
the one the only Ben Simon in my spot
for tomorrow so be sure to tune in for
that you don't want to miss a rare Ben
Simon appearance as he moves moves
things behind the camera these days now
interesting so I guess someone else is
going to tell me what to do is yes he
came there will be a great show Ben
Simon a person being a wonderful
producer for us yes yes well I think
that's it thank you for joining us
be sure to tune in tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
for more live coverage of the winter
chess classic thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you